[Música]
buenas tardes
gracias están despiertos querían
hoy les va hablar de el desarrollo esto
es un tema que siempre me apasionó desde
muy joven
chávez que desarrolla tiene muchas
facetas hay desarrollo económico en
desarrollo cultural académico industrial
y desarrollo en medicina de salud y que
ellos se juntan y forman una cierta
forma bienestar esa de la comunidad
yo creo que todavía mucho que vamos a
hacer por el bienestar de nuestra
comunidad
y especialmente mi angustia ver y sentir
como el mundo avanza en tecnología y en
colombia parecemos quedarnos siempre
estancados
mis primeros recuerdos de este tema del
desarrollo vienen de mi infancia
recuerdo en esas reuniones de familia
donde los tíos y los amigos terminaban
en una calurosa discusión de cómo
arreglar el país ustedes conocen esas
discusiones
mucho más tarde en mi vida especiales a
la universidad vuelvo a unas reuniones
sociales ya no está en colombia estoy en
boston
y veo que está sucediendo lo mismo y
extrañamente me siento muy atraído a esa
conversación y me uno y empiezo a
participar con más energía y me asombro
de las ideas de las de los análisis de
la profundidad de esta gente pero
tristemente me doy cuenta que se parecen
a esas conversaciones de mi infancia
donde poco atrás en día
entonces yo me puse a pensar cómo
hacemos para que esto trascienda nos
soltamos unos amigos digamos la primera
porque nos ocurre sacamos una charla más
grande
como 10 y una para 150 personas menos
200 nos llegaron 400 personas esa charla
fue un hit total y hoy en día se repite
sucedió hace unas pocas semanas en
harvard llamada colombia 2040 pero si
ustedes pero yo no tengo paciencia va a
esperar hasta el 2040
estoy paciencia como hasta el 2008
como veía que nada realmente se
materializaba decidí que era momento de
arremangarse la camiseta
y volver a mi ciudad natal a ver qué
podíamos hacer yo venía con un plan está
el plan me considero afortunado porque
en el mundo viví esta transformación
estos son dos ejemplos de cosas que se
consideran imposibles viaje espacial
privado y vehículos autónomos dijo los
que se manejaban solos este es el año
2003 2004 y a través de concursos
un curso con un premio de 10 millones de
dólares una empresa por inversión de 40
millones de dólares logró hacer el
primer cohete que llevar a una persona
al borde del espacio
y regresar dentro de una semana eso se
considera imposible la nasa la agencia
espacial europea considera que se
hubiera costado millones de horas de
desarrollo
y los carros autónomos también eran uno
de los hitos de la inteligencia
artificial desde el 2 desde el año 84
hasta el año 2001 se han invertido más o
menos 350 millones de dólares por parte
del ejército de eeuu para lograr
construir un vehículo que escondiera
solo y los mejores profesores las
mejores mentes en la industria decían
que era un hito posiblemente imposible
de lograr y con un premio de millones
dólares con estudiantes de stanford
lograron construir este vehículo en azul
que fue el primero en resolver el
problema pero detrás de él llegaron
estos otros dos vehículos tres
soluciones independientes con un premio
de dos millones de dólares entonces mi
plan perfecto me vengo para colombia
empieza otra con alcaldía con la
gobernación universidades y empresas
la verdad es que me sentía así como un
david frente a goliat a conocer la
historia
pues voy a usar esa historia como
analogía para lo que viene después
esa es nuestra interesante porque hay
muchas historias dentro de ella está la
historia de david el pequeño que ante la
adversidad supera o está la historia de
cómo los gigantes pueden caer con
facilidad pero la que más me gusta la
describe mal con carácter en su charla
de 2017
él dice por día no tenía ni chance
entrando esa pelea
como si los pequeños tenían las de ganar
ese día me interesa me vamos a ver es un
enfrentamiento militar goliat era la
infantería era un soldado a pie
pero david era artillero
esa onda puede girar a 300 revoluciones
por minuto soltar un proyectil de
mediana densidad y usada con precisión
es un arma mortal david lleva tecnología
a la pelea y por eso la plano fue justa
y como aprendió david a usar esta
tecnología
en academia militar con instructores
certificados
no cuidando a sus ovejas
de una montaña en el pasto tirando
piedras es una actividad cotidiana y eso
nos para pensar cuál sería el ambiente
cotidiano bajo el bajo el cual los
jóvenes de colombia se podrían preparar
para desarrollar tecnología
entonces nadie nos quiso comprar el
cuento de los concursos grandes eso era
muy complicado decidimos hacer cursos
pequeños
y esto fue relativamente exitoso pero yo
veía que todavía no estamos dando el
brinco a generar una transformación
tecnología porque porque estos concursos
estaban deseando más que todo para
incentivar a que los jóvenes entraran en
carreras técnicas eso ha sido un éxito
en los países industrializados lo llaman
stem
pero yo decía para colombia esto
básicamente nos va a convertir en
mejores exportadores de talento algo los
cuales ya somos muy buenos
entonces hace seis años nos llegó una
oportunidad de oro a las empresas
públicas de medellín se les ocurre que
quieren construir un vehículo solar para
competir en esta competencia del world
solar challenge de australia 3000
kilómetros cruzando el desierto
australiano
y cómo lo vamos a hacer y vamos a
contratar una empresa especializada en
carros solares contra el récord no
decidimos irónica de guaro y para los
que no saben el reto qué tan duro es
estas presiones referencia
es como ir de medellín a cartagena
medellín a cartagena y devolverse hasta
montería
lo hicimos con un grupo de estudiantes
voluntarios dos estudiantes al principio
estás loco cómo lo vas a hacer es que
los yates tienen algo que nosotros ya en
la edad media o nuestra edad ya no
tenemos y es tiempo
en serio
estos chicos invirtieron 28 semanas de
su tiempo y sumaron 6 mil horas hombre
antes de que el proyecto fuera firmado
por la universidad y por el pm los
adultos responsables no hacemos eso
no tenemos el tiempo pase lo literal
metros que físicamente imposible sin
embargo es el grupo de estudiantes
creció y lograron algo que parecía
imposible
este proyecto fue negado tres veces por
colciencias porque no teníamos
suficientes doctorados especializados
para construir el vehículo
y con esto tal no solamente eso lograron
terminar la carrera en el primer intento
pocos equipos lo logran hacer
cuando llegamos sorpresa éramos un éxito
mediático les entregan algo muy especial
el premio nacional de ingeniería que por
primera vez en su historia se le entrega
un proyecto que no es una obra civil es
un viaducto una represa el equipo del
proyecto se vuelve a ejecutar el equipo
crece es más diverso abre estudiantes de
todo el país que vienen a participar en
él
el resultado es mejor que grande novenos
entre 40 equipos internacionales y como
el gato digamos el genio ya se había
salido de la botella
otro grupo estudiantes diferentes decide
que tienes el mismo reto y esos son
administradores comunicadores psicólogos
se pone un reto más grande de pasajeros
y los llevan y el equipo crece siguen
trabajando y lo llevaron a competencia
en bélgica el cambio el carro falla
espectacularmente la medianoche sin
embargo el resto de los equipos deciden
otorgarles el premio al espíritu de
competencia para usted se preguntarán
cuál es el secreto
y hay que trabajar en equipo pero más
importante hay que retar a los equipos y
la palabra mía es concursar los
concursos ofrecen una serie de
condiciones muy favorables para este
tipo de desarrollo acuérdate que son
estudiantes son jóvenes es la primera
vez que realmente están haciendo algo
complejo en su vida
los cursos importantes porque porque las
reglas son claras
cuando la gente emprende la regla de
mercado no son necesariamente claras es
una de las primeras fuentes de
frustración de todos los emprendedores
la primera vez el segundo el estándar es
muy alto es una competencia
internacional ya no vas con lo que está
ok en la región bases contra los mejores
del mundo
y finalmente tiene un aspecto muy
chévere y es que cuando estos
estudiantes que construyen un vehículo
para quedar su carro al lado de otra
universidad del lado de stanford al lado
de michigan tokai del university de
holanda se dan cuenta que ellos pueden
ser tan buenos y su chip cambia
radicalmente se vuelven tecnólogos se
vuelven personas capaces de construir
sus propias soluciones uno de los
grandes formas que yo veo en nuestra
sociedad es que hemos asumido que la
tecnologías como saber
y realmente para mí la tecnología es una
forma de pensar es un estilo de vida
cuando la tecnología termina se
convierte en un saber
y hay que estar preparados para eso que
viene antes
un pequeño ejemplo ósea
yo les hablaba ahorita
qué pasa cuando nos reta un grupo de
jóvenes
este es un caso muy particular o manuel
vélez no sé cuántos años se demoró el
para graduarse de afip
dato tipico estudiante pero literalmente
permeaba liderazgo y este proyecto le
permitió al convertirse en un líder
natural y cuando amar a él vuelve esa
primera carrera juan manuel vaca lee y
construye el primer vehículo eléctrico
primer pulso eléctrico de colombia
evapora esta perspectiva desde méxico
hasta chile
ningún país produce buses eléctricos
una empresa de tecnología una industria
completa de tecnología naciente se
parecía al automotriz al aeronáutica a
la de barcos que otros países que hoy
los tenemos como referentes han hecho
cinco años invertimos y más o menos creo
que tenemos efectos sobre 100
estudiantes
logramos validar este modelo dentro a
fico imos el concepto de concursos y por
fin los tropicalizado para entender eso
cómo se aplicaba y cómo funciona nuestra
sociedad pero me parece que sin
estudiantes es muy poco
estamos más escala y mi meta es llegar a
más de 1.000 estudiantes en los próximos
cinco años
esta parte no la ensaya pero tengo
tiempo
porque porque yo quiero llegarle a mil
estudiantes
les voy a confesar una cosa cuando
estaba en el colegio
me apoya formulita
ya se pueden imaginar el cuadro
mis compañeros realmente sintieron mucho
cariño y no puedo decir que a mí me
dieron y si hay alguno viéndome live
tranquilo pues no le estoy sacando nada
pero eso decía mucho de mí yo necesite
salir de este país para encontrar los
retos que realmente me hacían vivir que
me hacían crecer
y haciendo concursos trabajando con los
estudiantes me di cuenta que colombia
está lleno
de formulitas está lleno de esos está
bits de esos chicos que traen la
tecnología a la batalla y saben vencer
entonces como yo no quiero que el
talento humano siga saliendo de este
país siento ese compromiso de hacerlo
estamos trabajando con algunas
fundaciones y con empresas y con otras
instituciones para que existan más
concursos
soy un convencido
de que los jóvenes de nuestro país
pueden desarrollar
casi cualquier reto
y de hecho esta es un poquito de la
fórmula mágica de cómo lo hicimos
fue un poquito de un gran engaño
podéis ir estafa pero
ese reto
logro digamos entusiasmar a una empresa
privada esa empresa privada o
público-privada poner los recursos y
esos recursos entusiasma a una entidad
plantilla no le quiere quedar mal a la
empresa privada la referente entonces la
universidad hace lo que puede y
realmente recurre a su recurso más
abundante que son los estudiantes y los
estudiantes a su mismo tiempo porque van
para un reto internacional sean
completamente motivados
muy importante en este proceso los retos
sean internacionales y es una cosa muy
cultural nuestra pero el hecho que el
reto sea internacional les brinda de
ellos una licencia social
la cantidad de horas la inversión de
estos estudiantes en estos proyectos es
gigante ellos sacrifican semestres ellos
bajan su promedio académico y ellos
deterioran la mayoría de sus relaciones
personales por fuera del equipo
se quedan sin novia y sin novio
pero el hecho de que van a representar
al país en la competida infernal les da
ese esa licencia yo no conozco ningún
papá que ha llegado a decirme jorge mi
hijo bajó al promedio 5.5
irónicamente he recibido algunos los
abrazos más calurosos de papas que me
dice mi hijo encontró su norte
en este taller
mi sueño es que colombia se tiene de
davis
y que eso es david se tumben a todos los
gigantes que están atravesados el
desarrollo de colombia muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]